In the fall of 2008, the economy
careened into unknown territory.
Forty-one percent told Gallup pollsters the
events then made them feel personally afraid.
Many felt the financial system could collapse.
Over the next several years, workers’ anxieties
about their jobs rose.
In Gallup’s data, between 2008 and 2009,
the number of Americans who feared losing
their job or having their pay cut doubled.
Many told pollsters they knew someone who
had lost a job.
Confidence in banks and financial institutions
plummeted.
Americans blamed banks and Wall Street for
greed; they also blamed regulators for a lack
of financial regulation which they believed
contributed to the crisis.
What has changed in the last decade?
Americans’ confidence about their jobs and
wages has returned to pre-crash levels, and
they feel very positive about the job market
right now.
Confidence in banks and Wall Street has inched
up.
But only small number of Americans believe
our financial system is more secure than it
was then.
Around a third gave that response to Pew in
2013 and 2015 while around 60 percent said
it was not.
How do you remember the financial crisis? Let us know in your comments?
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.